bonjour ma très chère julien messieurs
du snav arino c'est pas monsieur juste 9
de cette fois soit
julie tu n'as pas l'air très satisfaite
de me voir veut pas du tout françois
seulement j'attendais monsieur du snob
mais justement je l'attends également
avancé peut-être pour la même raison
moi je ne fais pas de secret comme toi
moi non plus alors je t'écoute mais
pourquoi moi
prend costumes ou d'europe alors voilà
monsieur du snob au jus dit tu vas bien
que tu meurs d'envié de commencer je
t'écoute alors voilà messieurs 10 9 a
invité un pique nique
aussi cet après midi mais moi aussi et
je ne sais ni le lieu
n'ont plus ni l'heure moi non plus voilà
pourquoi j'attends monsieur tout cela
avec impatience
donc comme moi
[Musique]
c'est vous monsieur d'histoire
maintenant voyons c'est moi et m on vend
pas comment pouvez-vous comprendre à mon
pad et celui de monsieur du snob le mien
je n'y avais plus en plus d'énergie car
oui en effet mais en fait tout et il
sait détour d'une fille mère je cherche
partout figurez vous qu'il vous inviter
à pique-niqué que vous ne savez ni le
lieu ni l'heure hamma comment le
savez-vous et bien mademoiselle fut-elle
julie et moi nous sommes dans le même
cas bonjour tout le monde argent désunir
mais comment faites vous tout cela va
pas regarder alors qu'en excellents
pique nique nous attend quasiment chaque
suisse innovant après que moi je n'en
ferai rien quasi mulhouse est le premier
ou goethe à faire ensemble après les
faits c'est nazi tomber mais je ne peux
pas
ben justement moi non plus on rejette
pas et moi j'avoue qu'une petite
limonade
si vous voulez mon avis c'est une
plaisanterie et même une très mauvaise
plaisanterie dans monsieur du snob alors
vous faites ce que vous voulez mais moi
je retourne chez moi car j'ai une
excellente carte au noir avec des
sardines qui m'attend alors ça je crois
que casimir a raison il faut abandonner
cette idée de pique nique c'est dommage
[Musique]
voilà un goûter dont je me souviendrai
jusqu'au prochain du thé au citron et
messieurs avec cette jupe l'ennemi pas
plus après ses décors et une finition
par ton noir quelle chance que casimir
soit parti au pique nique de monsieur du
snob sinon il aurait fallu partager la
tarte en deux tandis que là
je voulais manger toute entière
ces trois quasi mais oui tu rentres déjà
et le pique nique de monsieur dix neuf
romans pour van léonard il n'y a pas eu
pique nique c'était une mauvaise farce
de ce grand échalas du snob et que s'est
il passé bon je ne veux même plus en
parler non je vais plutôt me remonter le
moral en buvant à un bon thé au citron
tu arrive trop tard casimir il n'y a
plus de thé j'ai tout vu ah ben on voit
ça ne fait rien j'aurais simplement
manger une bonne part de tarte aux noix
avec des sardines ou kazimierz c'est à
dire vrai comme tu devais goûter au
pique nique de monsieur juste membres
j'ai mangé l'un tarte ouais tu as mangé
toute la tarte à autre tu connais
casimir pas d'un seul coup mais je n'ai
mangé que la tarte aux noix et et je
t'ai laissé mes sardines
décidément je n'ai plus d'amis
messieurs bonjour encore en faisant
émerger une lettre pour toi pour moi oui
merci son pc
voyons ça
c'est à temps d écouter sa voix mon cher
casimir le pique nique surprise aura
lieu à 5h dans la crique bleus
je compte sur toi à tout à l'heure
fulbert en scène du snav et moi
à terme pas de jambes d'antan par an
pendant
mes amis j'ai reçu l'invitation de
monsieur du snob je sais où a lieu le
pique nique nous pouvons partir
quand il dort pas c'est
simple je veux être le premier à avoir
reçu l'invitation oui
j'ai bien envie de partir sans les
attendre mais ce ne sera quand même pas
gentil non non et comme je suis un
monstre gentil je vais attendre
j'ai une idée pour passer le temps je
vais pour une fois me chanter ma chanson
pour moi tout ça là
[Musique]
habitude chansons et hop
imagination
je vous emmène dans notre île
[Musique]
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui périt
avec casimir
hamon
orange
[Musique]
ici donc un an et demi si l'on me dit
maladroit
et pour moi
je sais jouer de la musique
je suis né ce matin' camille
si j'aime la grâce au son choix c'est
mon choix et mon droit
avec une chance
un peu d'imagination
je emmène dans notre it is au pied du
bonheur tranquille
ces couleurs rencontrer
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre aux tiberi
ap le cas
j'ai une
machine elle une idée fantastique
je mange au nul ou bi pour les gars mais
je n'en sommes
qu'à la campagne
j'ai vu ma ville de cocagne au cinéma 4
3 c'est mon droit
[Musique]
avec une chanson
imaginez
en mai nous dans notre ici 2
au pays du bonheur remplie
il est ouvert au pays
ne soyez pas terroriste
je suis le bon qui fait rire
ma mère casini
[Applaudissements]
je
et voilà ils ne sont toujours pas
revenus ça alors je ne comprends pas son
peut être parti sans moi
je lis françois massé le futur où êtes
vous et finir quasi mir kazemi
j'espère que j'allais partir 106 1000 g
le lieu du pique nique moi aussi après
écoute et il faut partir immédiatement
car d'ici à la crique bleus il y a une
bonne heure de marche et qui est
parti sans moi pour surpasser au soleil
il fait pas bon marché alors j'ai pris
ma bicyclette en facteur emmenez-moi sur
votre porte bagages en mon pauvre
casimir mais je n'ai pas de porte
bagages sur votre cadre alors que fout
casimir tu joues beaucoup trop gros
comment ça je ne suis pas plus gros que
vous voici casimir tue beaucoup plus
gros que le facteur voyons bon et bien
puisque c'est comme ceci vous allez voir
petite malle magique
fais moi une place sur le vélo du
facteur ap
et voilà
n'irai pas si
casimir je ne peux s'attendent les noms
j'en fasse cette place à mademoiselle
futile
mais l'on
sait bien qu'à cela ne tienne
attention petit mâle
up
ces
annonces n'ont alors pourtant plus tant
pis encore une fois
une place pour moi aussi
mais elles n'ont pas mais c'est qu'un
sens et ça et moi alors tant pis
regardez bien
il n'ya plus que moi ah non non non non
non casimir je ne peux pas t'en donner
parce que je promis à leonardo passé le
prendre mais léonard a déjà eu son
goûter bon il se laissera bien
convaincre en avant
vite vite vite ma patinette non mais
alors il ne sera pas dit que je
laisserais ce renard goûté deux fois
[Musique]